alright guys so we are here today to
talk about work at a startup let's
really quickly do some introductions so
Jared why don't you start hey I'm Jared
I'm a partner here at YC the way I got
into YC was I did a YC company and one
of the earliest batches is coming to
called Scribd and then I joined YC 3
years ago I was a partner go Matt hey
I'm Matt long I was a co-founder of a
company that went through Y Combinator
back in winter 2010 called Crocodoc and
now I'm a software engineer here at YC
I've been here for a little over a
little under a year now cool and you
guys in addition to a few other people
at YC have been working on a product
called work at startup so Matt could you
describe what it is yeah so work at a
start-up as a common application for
engineers that were interested in
working at a start-up and in particular
a YC company they'll go through a lot of
kind of typical biographical questions
about themselves and their experience
and background and then they're able to
kind of choose their preferences for
what sort of company and role they're
looking for we make all this information
available to the founder of founders of
all of our YC companies who can then
kind of browse and search through them
to find what they're looking for kind of
indicate their interest and start to
start conversations with them that will
hopefully lead the some hires cool and
yeah so why why make this why make this
instead of you know just relying on the
existing infrastructure out there
yes I guess hiring is notoriously hard
among startups and in Silicon Valley you
know it's just so it's so much intense
competent competition you know the more
established players in the tech industry
and sure enough you know just like
internal surveys we've done with
founders of YC companies kind of confirm
that we're overwhelmingly hiring and in
particular hiring engineers is kind of
the number one problem they face
following going through the YC program
so we YC you decide we should take the
same approach we've done with everything
and try to apply software to this help
scale and you'll find a get a nice
scalable solution in just another way
that YC could kind of help
our portfolio companies and kind of got
made made our own kind of hiring portal
that's a little bit kind of particular
to the way and the types of companies
that go through YC mm-hmm and so Jerry
do you have experience with this
directly having hired quite a bit at
Scribd
before and you were also part of the
work of startup before was known as work
at a start-up conference in 2010 right
yeah so it's actually not a new idea per
se for YC to try to help its companies
hire hacker news from the very beginning
when we first created it back in I think
2009 part of the goal was to help
companies hire and so it's had a job
session from day one and I was at my
startup I used the hacker news job
section a lot and was incredibly helpful
for hiring I think probably half the
engineering team that we hired came
through how to use and that's not
atypical for YC companies so we have
sort of a long history of this we have
also long had an internal forum for YC
founders or they share candidates that
aren't right for them but could be great
for somebody else and that's also worked
extremely well and so it was the the
origins of this project were kind of
like we saw that this was working and
that there is tremendous demand for it
and everybody wanted us to do more and
so the workers start a product is trying
to build just a better more efficient
more sophisticated version of the hacker
news jobs board and the internal form
that we've had for a long time mm-hmm in
particular what are the additions that
differentiate it from a you know HN job
posting for example yeah absolutely so
the way I think about hiring is like
it's fundamentally a mattering problem
right there's a great company for
everyone and for every company there's a
set of people who would be perfect for
them but it's really hard to make that
match happen and it's especially hard
for startups for large companies like a
Microsoft they hire people of all kinds
and so the the matching just becomes
easier because they're hanging for so
many roles of cloud a Microsoft there's
good chance there's a role there that
like could be a good fit for you yeah
but with startups who are only hiring
for a couple roles
that don't have brand names you don't
know who they are what they do if you'd
be interested what roles they're hiring
for and so the matching prom is
particularly hard for startups and
that's why we've been working really
hard on it Matt would be a great person
talk about some of the the ways that
we're trying to solve a mashing problem
it's still it's still early days it's a
really hard problem but I think we have
some interesting ideas cool yes I think
kind of the main thing we're going to be
looking at is just kind of around kind
of what sort of culture and company fuel
and potential employees are kind of
interested in you know of anything from
kind of more objective measures like
size of the company number of people in
it whether or not they're profitable or
not like how important is out to a
potential new engineer and then also of
course kind of ranging in though what's
kind of sort of like skills and
technologies the engineers have mastered
the various degrees and kind of lining
that up against you know the the tech
stack of the beginning company is using
and then kind of again going more into
the culture things kind of looking for
kind of what's more important to them
you know just in terms of excuse me are
they interested in solving more kind of
like product focused questions or really
digging in the like deep kind of
technical hard technical problems
kind of just things like that kind of
just what's most important to them or
what they're looking for and then of
course we can get all this I'm for me
exact kind of sort of information from
all the companies that are going to be
in the system as well you know so
that'll kind of give us kind of two sets
of data to kind of match against each
other and we think you know we're pretty
confident there's this will be a nice
way to kind of filter out the most
interesting and the best matching
companies to the top of for these
applicants and the founders as well of
companies just kind of show them which
applicants might be you know right for
them yeah how does that how do the
companies report and measure their own
culture in these engineering problems
like what questions exactly are they
entering it's yeah that's a good
question we actually haven't put these
questions directly in their final form
in front of founders just yet but really
you could go like I kind of like the
application that's on work at a startup
calm
and you know go through like the career
and culture section and then you can
imagine there being a fairly similarly
worded question that we're gonna pose to
our founders you know and just to start
with you know it'll kind of be kind of
trusting them they answer them honestly
you know about you know what's what the
conditions are like at their office and
just kind of like the state of their
company whether or not we're gonna have
to sort of like editorial eyes that are
curated at all or you know make sure
everything lines up or the reality it's
kind of yet to be seen but certainly
like the star will it'll this be
self-reported from the founders
themselves I'm curious about how you
guys have been doing the matching thus
far because this product has been around
when did when was the initial like early
beta launch so the very first beta was
in the middle of December 2017 so just
around six months ago okay and what did
it look like back then because I think
it might be interesting for people to
find out like how this is evolved to
this point yeah so back then it was um
just the other data we're gathering from
advocates and that wasn't nearly as much
as we have now and it's kind of pretty
simple watered down version of what you
might you know be asked on other kind of
hiring portals like hired or AngelList
back then it was pretty basic stuff you
know just kind of who you are you know
with your email address a few freeform
questions like why do you want to work
at a start-up things like that and kind
of purposefully we steered away at that
point from asking people for like I
resume mm-hmm just because there is a
lot of kind of thoughts internally that
it may not be the best thing or you know
the best way to kind of judge someone
based on where they worked before they
kind of look at them more holistically
which is especially true at startups you
know it's kind of finding someone that's
gonna be kind of aligned with your
mission can get on board with that kind
of like the goals of the company much
more we think then you know that might
matter at a larger company um with a
much bigger headcount so it's kind of
like a smaller and kind of different set
of questions and you might normally see
and they yeah we didn't really focus on
work history at all or even education
especially mmm you know what school you
went to shouldn't matter nearly as much
as kind of like what neat stuff you've
done as an engineer
you know more recently mm-hmm and it
certainly has evolved a lot since then
we actually now do ask you for a resume
just because you know after after not
having it for a long time a lot of times
the first thing founders would tell us
you know when we ask them how you know
how they're liking the product is well
this is great but I don't know anything
about them and kind of the first thing I
have to do all the time is just go look
at their LinkedIn profile okay I kind of
learned a bit more so you know we're
taking that feedback and kind of
iterating on that quite a bit
hmm any other surprises that you've
learned from founders who are getting
you know all these applications comes
through their door um one one surprise
is actually the diversity of candidates
that companies are looking for um you
know when we first started we worried
that like it might be hard for us to
find great companies for people who are
not in the Bay Area because so many of
the companies that we have are based
here it turns out not the case we
actually have companies now hire in over
12 countries we have a ton of companies
who are hiring for remote only roles and
just the range of like the different
skill sets that people are looking for
everything from full stack web data
science to DevOps and sort of a whole
range of experience levels as well um as
mint that were were able to find good
matches for almost everyone who signs up
hmm okay so I'm curious about before we
talk about the conference I'm interested
in talking about the recent hñ thread
and what were the learnings from that so
earlier this week you I think it was
Jared I think you posted it right
basically a question to the community
right what are the pros and cons of
working at a startup in 2018 what were
the takeaways yeah so it was a pretty
amazing hacker news thread we got about
a thousand comments in response into the
question yeah and they were really
insightful like people shared some
amazing experiences of working in big
companies of working at small companies
of founding their own company of being a
consultant and how all of them compared
and
there are the reason that we did it was
we wanted to really understand what
people liked and didn't like about
working on a start-up and in particular
what YC could do to help because I think
we're in a position to be able to help
with some of the things that aren't
working as well as they could be so some
of the things people really like about
working at a start-up is for sure the
autonomy the feeling that you're able to
really move the needle on an on an
organization that like the company that
you've worked at like might not have
been successful if you hadn't taken that
job the ability to bond with a small
team the ability to work on like really
interesting problems and with the newest
technologies the ability to have control
over the technologies that you use
rather than just inheriting a tech stack
that's already set so certainly some
interesting pros and then on the cons
the most prominent was compensation and
what we heard is compensation is
important people if you're going to take
a job you got to feel like the
compensation is fair and startups have
to be fair how to be paying fair
compensation in order to attract the
best talent and that's always been true
I think it's gotten a little bit harder
recently as compensation for engineers
across the industry around the world has
gone up but what some people on how to
do is may not yet know is that the
conversation that startups has gone up a
lot as well and so I think we may be
closer than they think but there's still
more that startups have to do on that
front
transparency is also very important
where people need to feel like if a big
part of the compensation package is
equity in the startup that they really
understand how to value that equity and
how to compare it against other offers
mm-hmm that's I think a basic thing that
all all startups can really do better
when hiring people
job security is very important to people
sometimes when you're working in
early-stage startup it can feel less
secure than working in a big company
this startup can go out of business I
think this is actually something that YC
and work at a start-up can help with a
lot because while working at any
individual startup may not be as secure
as working at a large company
hopefully working for startups in
general can be even more secure because
if the startup that you're working at
now doesn't work out there's going to be
20 other startups who are going to like
value the great work that you did there
and want to hire you immediately mm-hmm
yeah especially within a network such as
the YC community yeah another thing to
be clear about I guess if it hasn't been
mentioned we're gonna start up is
working at YC companies like startups
around the world in general yeah Matt
did you learn anything from the thread
um I think yeah just that a compensation
came up so frequently it was a bit
surprising to me because I guess for me
that was kind of already unknown
quantity yeah going to work at a startup
you're probably you know in the general
case going to be taking a somewhat lower
salary than you might get at a you know
one of the larger Fang companies so just
that there is kind of so much is very
black-and-white around that like you
know some of the comments like why would
you go work at a startup and you can
make double the amount you know at a
large company this just doesn't make
sense and to me you know like yes you
know face value that might be true but
there's other kind of non-financial
reasons you might choose or want to go
work at the startup you know which I
think it's really important that you
have to have these other kind of issues
you know like like Jarrod mentioning or
this kind of forming these close bonds
of the small team can be really
appealing the people and you know
certainly that was one of the big kind
of things I look back on from my startup
experience that were like me and my
co-founders granted I wasn't an employee
I was a co-founder but just kind of the
bonds I formed with them you know
there's still to this day some like my
you know closest friends and it's just
things like that I think are kind of
like one of the unique kind of things
that startups have to offer
mm-hm and just so that wasn't kind of
got brushed over a lot in a lot of
it was a bit surprising to me but it
makes sense again because you know
finances are important and if you're a
software engineer right now if it is
possible to make you know a pretty nice
salary at a lot of places yeah with you
know relatively low risk so for sure did
remote work play a big role in the in
the thread were people looking for that
or it did yeah I mean a lot of the
feedback centered on the insane cost of
housing in the Bay Area and in a few
other large cities and ask the question
why tech is so concentrated in this area
and a lot of people suggested that one
way that startups could compete with big
companies for talent is to be more
flexible on that you allow remote work
to have offices and other markets where
the housing is not so insane and I think
that's really interesting feedback and
it's definitely a trend that we've seen
among the YC companies more and more of
them are taking advantage of that yeah
absolutely I mean I think like zapier is
a great example of one of those
companies they were paying people to
deal okay from the bay last year which
was interesting yeah I think they got a
couple people to do it alright let's
talk about the conference so you guys
are doing a work at a startup conference
in July correct yep what are the details
cool
so the work to serve Commerce is
actually not the first time YC has done
it we did it a long time ago back in
2010 and I know because I presented had
it and it was it was great and the only
reason that we didn't keep doing it was
that it was a lot of work and YC was
very short-staffed at the time and so we
just sort of like paused it for a number
of years but I'm really excited that
we're going to bring it back and YC has
grown a lot since then we're ten times
the size and so the converse is gonna be
about ten times the size how did Wes
back yeah it's gonna be really big yeah
and so how it works is it's similar to
ycs demo day but for employees instead
of investors so we're gonna start with a
keynote so justin khan and sam altman
are going to give keynote talks about
working at a start-up why you should
work at a startup how did
startups what kind of compensation he
should be looking for how to negotiate
an offer and then we're gonna have
thirty five rapid-fire pitches from the
founders of YC companies we've got an
extremely broad range of companies
coming who are hiring a very broad range
of role so we have everything from like
established successful companies like
instacart doordash and planned grid hair
founders are going to come and give up
personal presentation and then we have a
whole bunch of like really small
companies that like just raised a seed
round and are looking for engineers
number one or two and are giving out
large amounts of equity in return and
then sort of everything in between and
we have companies who are hiring for
roles like the most common are probably
like full stack web and back-end web and
front-end web but there's a whole range
of other roles as well we have the
companies who are hiring for your like
co-founder CTO roles we have have
companies who are hiring for machine
learning and AI and DevOps and robotics
engineers and embedded system design so
I found that like particularly cool just
just how broad the ranges and we have
what's the experience gonna be like for
an attendee what can I expect so I think
the most the most compelling reason to
go as an attendee is if you think you
might be interested in working in a
start-up but you're not really sure
which one or how to think about it okay
if you come to the work and start with
that you'll get in a short period of
time like a really compressed view of
what's out there and the market what
your options are as an engineer right
now and in 2018 and you'll get to talk
to the founders because after after the
talks we're gonna have just like a
mingling session where you can just walk
up to the founders of any company and
had to know them hmm okay and so as an
engineer in a mat you're an engineer
right now how do you think someone ought
to prepare themselves to attend the
event or should they not worry about it
and just show up um I think it kind of
depends on your background where you're
coming from if you're an engineer that's
already worked at a start-up or might be
you know kind of familiar that's what's
going on and what employment might look
like how to start up then
you don't need to do much you might want
to you know research the list of
companies that are presenting anyone
should do this I guess you know just so
you kind of know what to expect and
which ones you might be interested and
listening to because I believe there is
going to kind of be a separate track of
other talks going on at the same time so
sometimes you have to pick and choose
between you know if you're gonna be
listening to the presentations or
something else that's going on so you
know familiarize yourself with the
companies and then for someone that has
that never worked at a start-up before
you probably have a set of ideas like
what it would be like to work at a
start-up you know based on what you've
read on Hacker News or elsewhere on the
Internet
so I would say kind of try to push all
those out of your head and kind of come
with an open mind because you know we
like to think that especially YC
startups Eric are gonna present you with
like a kind of a nicer all around kind
of like employment offer and no kind of
you know tried to ignore any like horror
stories you've kind of heard before and
how Madame might be but also you know
kind of recognizing like we're talking
about earlier that you know you may need
to take kind of hit on salary if you are
coming from a larger company and you
know everyone else everyone's going to
have their own kind of take on whether
or not that works for them in their
current situation I think I just kind of
coming with an open mind and kind of
being willing the you think about
working in an industry or for you know a
size company that you haven't ever
thought about before will be the best
way they get ready for it cool and just
in practical terms like should they
bring a resume with them that's a great
any that's a great point I guess yeah we
didn't mention this but actually there
there is gonna be a sort of a selection
process for who gets to attend since
unfortunately we don't have unlimited
space at YC use office and Mountain
View's and so everyone will be required
to kind of fill out the normal
application that's on work at a start-up
calm right now as if you were going to
be using the site online there will be a
special section where you can indicate
that you're interested in attending the
the conference which will kind of treat
your application a little bit
differently and you know we'll just kind
of tell us you who's all interested so
we can then kind of go through
where we're gonna have the very
difficult job of you know selecting who
gets to attend so that that's the main
thing whether or not you need to bring
paper resumes you know like if you
really want to we're not going to stop
you from doing that but we are gonna try
to have a little bit of a technological
approach is just kind of making it easy
for people at the at the conference to
kind of indicate interest in companies
and is it open to people not currently
living in the Bay Area yeah anyone that
once they come I think you know we're
not going to stop you of course the
you'd have to pay your own way here and
all that but you know I think it's more
about if you're willing to work in a
location where most of these companies
are located you know if you're willing
to relocate the earth and that I'll
probably be the bigger kind of will
drive the decision a bit more but
certainly on any one thought from the
bear is very welcome to attend we are
also going to livestream the conference
online for for anyone who who can't make
it out here and I wanted to mention one
other thing that I'm very excited about
for the conference which is for the
first time we're gonna have hardware
demos so we do this for demo day for
investors um and back in 2010 when we
did the first work at a start-up
conference we didn't have really any
companies who are building hard work but
now we have a lot of companies who are
building all kinds of cool stuff so um
at the conference there's going to be a
full-size self-driving truck from
Starsky robotics that will hopefully be
self-driving itself around the parking
lot nice we're going to have an actual
satellite from astronomer Flocka of the
one that's currently in orbit around the
earth we're gonna have well we are
working on getting permission to land a
giant industrial drone in the parking
lot of Mountain View that's a drone
that's made by a company called the LAN
sea and it's so large that we need to
get permission from the city of Mountain
View to have it land there Wow cool yeah
I think that like reframing the just the
terms start up to be much broader than
SAS companies is an important thing that
you guys are doing yeah I think it's a
great point I think a lot of Engineers
don't realize just how
any options there are in startups these
days we have several companies attending
who are doing like really hard science
stuff they're doing autonomous driving
and mapping and hardcore machine
learning computer vision kinds of things
yeah you guys have been working on this
now for over six months what are the
metrics you've been tracking and how is
it going yeah so so far is going
extremely well we've we haven't really
announced it at all we've just been
running it very quietly we added a link
on the Y Combinator homepage and so far
we've already gotten over 3,000
engineers to sign up and fill out a
profile more exciting to me is that of
those 3,000 engineers the vast majority
of them have gotten at least one message
from a YC company so companies are
actually really using the product and if
you are an engineer and you sign up like
the odds are good that you will get in
touch with the company over 80% of the
YC companies who are hiring engineers
are already on it they filled out their
own private files there's a directory on
the site where you can browse all the
companies who are hiring engineers so
the response from the YC community has
been great awesome all right guys thanks
for making time and so what's the URL if
people want to sign up or apply to go to
the conference yes you can find all this
work at a start-up com great thank you
Thanks great thanks
you